foreign
's in Tampa hey Ryan welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave and Rachel thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
so my question is should I sell my house
should my wife and I sell our house to
pay off our debt
um and a little bit of backstory is
um we have we're a family of five and
we're currently living in a two Warren
and two one is that what you said two
bedroom one bath
yes we're in a 2-1
um so and we have 83 000 worth of debt a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
equity
um so our thought processes if we still
learn how we need we need a bigger house
we've got three kids so
um and our thought processes if we sell
our house we can pay off the debt have
enough money for our emergency fund
because we're currently in baby step two
and then grant for a couple years and
just do baby step 3B
how long you been married
uh eight eight years how long you been
in this house
three years how long you've been working
this plan this Ramsey stuff
this Ramsay stuff I've been Dave ish for
well we've we've been in Davis for a
couple years no when did you start
actually getting so serious that you're
willing to sell your house
oh a couple weeks ago okay
did you guys make it here Ryan
uh 80 000
80 000 okay
um
okay I I'm I'm nervous that the reason
you want to sell the house is more
because you don't like the house
not necessarily to
change the behavior to get out of debt
yeah
so like this would be like a silver
bullet that would just like fix it all
but what I would be worried about Ryan
is like have you guys fixed your
behavior like have you have you guys
created you don't ever felt the
sacrifice of new habits and you don't
have that change that course you know
the track record of new habits that's
the danger and if if you wave this magic
wand and your debt is gone and you don't
change your beha your habits and you
stay ish
because two whole weeks you've been
engaged I mean come on really I mean if
you if that the danger is you go back to
ish and then you're going to be a renter
that's broke
right so yes I would do your plan
but
you know you and your wife are going to
have to put the kids to bed and take
each other's hands and look at the other
one deeply in the eyes and say if we
don't follow this plan exactly I'm gonna
kill you I mean really I mean we have to
do this
it has to get like down in your soul
like ah because if you if you don't this
is a really bad idea
if you're gonna get stuck in rinterland
right yeah and we don't want that no we
don't want that so mathematically you do
get a better place I did what you're
doing Sharon and I did it when uh Rachel
was a kid we different reasons we sold a
home in up in Nashville the school
system sucked and we were driving 45
minutes one way twice a day so several
hours on the road to put kids in private
schools several thousand dollars a year
per kid and I'm like God this is nuts I
can sell this move to a different County
where the public schools are excellent
rent clear up everything and I don't
have the drive and I don't have the
private school Bill and so that's what
we did but it was part of and so
everything worked good but it's also
part of a change we lived we rented this
crappy rental for two years my wife will
still tell you stories about how much
she hated that house uh and then we were
able to buy a house but it was it was
part of a plan it wasn't a trapdoor
Escape mechanism and then I didn't deal
with the deal with
right
so you you gotta promise you
your wife's got to promise you your
wife's got to promise her you got to
promise her that that we're going to
lean in and stop the foolishness
if you go through with this I like your
plan other than that
so Rachel's right
okay so if I give you a Financial Peace
University to get you guys going will
you promise me both of you watch every
stinking lesson every minute of every
lesson and you have a conversation with
the coordinator and with the class and
you join the group in Financial Peace if
you promise me you'll do all that I'll
give it to you free
yes I do absolutely okay and you and
your wife yeah now because that if
you'll get in that group you join this
group of people to give you positive
peer pressure to not do stupid or ish
anymore
and that's that's what I'm afraid for
you because you don't have a Tracker if
you told me you've been doing this six
or eight months and you'd already paid
off thirty thousand dollars worth of
debt making 80 and you guys are on a
tight budget and you and your wife are
close-knit and unified and we were
getting after it it'd make this call
instant yep to go do what you're talking
about yeah and that's always the danger
with you know we even get people that
get an inheritance or that you know some
type of large amount of money comes into
their possession and they're able which
is a blessing to be able to knock you
know the debt out but again Ryan like
you buckling down and really promising
and you guys are in a hard season with
three little kids and you know it's a
lot and so you can't allow the stress of
Life the exhaustion that you guys feel
to get you back in habit and habits that
got you here in the first place so truly
staying the course is what is going to
be it's what's going to be huge and it's
exciting right and on the flip side it's
like if that part is true then you guys
are going to be really far ahead and
these steps and you guys are gonna
you're gonna feel a lot of freedom which
is which is really great and rent the
cheapest thing you can rent that is a
bigger nicer house it's not a two one
with five people okay but don't go rent
the Taj Mahal because every dollar you
spend on rent is going to slow down your
savings
for a purchase later
so the house we rented I just explained
to you my wife was not happy with it it
was not glamorous it was the only thing
it did is meet the goal of getting our
other household and getting in the
correct County where the kids could be
in school system and uh so that that you
know and we didn't have the private
school bill and we didn't have the drive
anymore so we got quality of life we got
money back and and you know our
our rent was not that High
um even back in the day but yeah uh well
back then you know when dinosaurs roamed
the Earth you could get cheap rent but
yeah no I mean it's it's a it's a thing
it's a process that you're you're
resetting your mind in this thing and
it's just very important that you do
this right so you know getting getting
the Habit patterns that are it it you
know I made a comment about donuts
earlier and it's exactly true though on
that the the correlation with Fitness
is I mean Fitness is not a one-time
event yep it's a daily event
um of of nutrition and caloric intake
and calorie burned with exercise and
choices that you make and choices with
everything controlling the person in
your mirror you know I mean it's
incremental people who are vastly
successful at their marriage didn't send
flowers one time to their wife
they every day every week do something
in their marriage it's not a singular
event you can't go be a jerk for forever
and then go on one cruise and she's
happy that's not how this works